.
BACK TO YOU GUYS.
>> Carley: ASHLEY STROHMIER
LIVE FOR US, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, ASHLEY, LOVE YOU,
APPRECIATE IT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR DAVID WEBB.
DoD OFFICIALS TO LEAVE THEIR
MILITARY JOB BY MANAGING THE
PERSONAL PROPERTY OF MIGRANTS TO
REAL PREP, CLEAN PRESCRIPTION
MEDICINE RUNS FOR MIGRANTS,
SUPPLY DISTRIBUTION.
HOW WAS THIS POSSIBLE?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, LET'S
START WITH A LIE, THE LIGHTS AT
THE BORDER IS SECURE.
ASHLEY JUST TALKED ABOUT
VENEZUELANS MORE COMING ACROSS
THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
MORE COMING BECAUSE COLUMBIA HAS
A PROBLEM.
THEY CAN'T TAKE THEM IN.
THAT IS ONE OF THE COUNTRIES
TURNING THEM AWAY.
GO A LITTLE BIT FURTHER AND THIS
IS IMPORTANT ON THE TIMELINE.
THE FIRST REQUEST SENT
APRIL 12TH OF THIS YEAR BY
DEPUTY SECRETARY JOHN TO DHS.
THERE WAS A PROBLEM AT THE
BORDER.
THE DIGITAL SIGNATURE ON THIS
DOCUMENT IS OCTOBER 7TH.
IT IS BECAUSE NOW THERE IS A
PROBLEM THEY CAN NO LONGER
CONTAIN.
THEY COULDN'T CONTAIN IT TO
BEGIN WITH.
THEY NEVER HAD AN INTENT TO
CONTAIN IT AND NOW ALL OF A
SUDDEN THEY HAVE TO PRETEND THEY
WERE DOING SOMETHING.
THIS POINTS OUT THE GET INVOLVED
PLAYER.
THE FALSEHOOD WHAT IS GOING ON.
HE IS A LIAR AND THERE'S NO
OTHER WAY TO PUT IT IN THE
BORDER IS NOT SECURE AND ON TOP
OF THAT, TAXPAYER DOLLARS GOING
TO PAY FOR MAIN SERVICES WITH
DoD OFFICIALS.
PEOPLE SHOULD BE PROTECTING OUR
COUNTRY.
ARE THE ONES BEING ASKED TO GO
BASICALLY PLAY MAY.
>> Carley: THAT IS THE KEY
THERE.
>> Todd: TO YOUR POINT,
COMPLETE ADMISSION BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION THEIR POLICIES
HAVE FAILED.
BUT LOOKING AHEAD, DAVE IF YOU
READ THIS LIST OF TEXTS, DHS'S
RECRUITING TO STAFF A HOTEL.
WHAT IS THE NEXT WAY THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS GOING TO ROLL
OUT THE RED CARPET FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE CROSSING OUR BORDER
ILLEGALLY?
THEY ARE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
HERE.
WHAT THEY ARE DOING IS ILLEGAL.
AND TREATING $1,000 A NIGHT
HOTEL GUESTS.
>> THEY ARE UNDERPERFORMING
HOTELS AND IN STATEN ISLAND IF
YOU SAW STATEN ISLAND AND OTHERS
A WEEK AGO.
BUT NOW YOU NEED STAFF AND YOU
HAVE TO FEED PEOPLE, YOU HAVE TO
CLEAN THE HOTELS AND TAKE CARE
OF THEM.
I GUESS THEY CAN VIOLATE FEDERAL
LAW AND HIRE ILLEGAL ALIENS.
THAT IS AGAINST FEDERAL LAW.
THEY CAN'T DO THAT BECAUSE THAT
IS TOO OBVIOUS.
>> Carley: WE ARE TALKING
DoD OFFICIALS BEING TAKEN OFF
THE MILITARY JOBS, THE DRUGS TO
PROTECT THIS NATION TO BE SENT
TO THE SOUTHERN BORDER TO
ESSENTIALLY DO MADE WORK RATHER
THAN SHUT THE BORDER DOWN AND
KEEP EVERYBODY SAFE.
THAT WAY, ALSO MAYORKAS SAID
RECENTLY HOW HE'S BLAMING
REPUBLICANS SAY AGAIN, THEY KEEP
SAYING THE BORDER IS WIDE
OPEN, WHICH IS "TO SMUGGLERS.
SO IT IS REALLY REPUBLICANS
FAULT.
>> YOU KNOW THAT PHRASE WORDS
HAVE MEANING?
IN THIS CASE, THE ACTION WENT
WELL AHEAD OF THE WORDS.
THEY HAVE NOT SECURE THE BORDER.
THEY HAVE NOT CONTINUED TO BUILD
PHYSICAL BARRIERS.
THEY HAVE NOT LET THE POLICY GO
FORWARD, CBP OFFICERS GO OUT AND
ACTUALLY PICK PEOPLE UP.
THE CUTAWAYS, THE MILLIONS,
WITHIN THE LAST YEAR OR
SO, WE'VE HAD TOTAL ENCOUNTERS
4.5 MILLION ENCOUNTERS HOWEVER
THEY HAVE WORKED OUT AT THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
4.5 MILLION WITH 25,000 AGENTS.
DO THE MATH, PEOPLE, THEY ARE
LYING TO YOU.
>> Todd: IN THE MEANTIME DAVID
WEBB, FOX POLL SHOWS HALF OF
AMERICANS BELIEVE THE U.S. IS
MOVING AWAY FROM CAPITALISM AND
TOTAL SOCIALISM.
60% OF PEOPLE SAY THAT IS A BAD
THING.
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOU ABOUT THE
OTHER 40% WHO DON'T THINK
SOCIALISM IS THAT BAD?
>> THE PROBLEM IS 40% KEEPS
GETTING OLD AND I THINK IT IS
ACTUALLY LESS WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHO AND WHAT THEY WANT TO APPEAR
GROUP AND I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT
IS THE PERCENTAGE OF THAT GROUP
THAT REALLY BELIEVE IN THIS
MARCH TOWARD SOCIALISM.
THAT CONCERNS ME MORE.
POLLING ASIDE, WE HAVE A PROBLEM
WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE GOTTEN TOO
COMFORTABLE GIVEN WHAT WAS ONCE
CALLED GOVERNMENT CHEESE,
GOVERNMENT HANDOUTS TO
MINORITIES.
TO KEEP PEOPLE IN THE PROJECTS.
IF YOU WANT THIS COUNTRY TO KEEP
GOING FORWARD AND BECOME A
NATIONWIDE PROJECT, KEEP SUPPORT
IN THAT.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN GOVERNMENT
RUNS OUT OF MONEY A.K.A.
TAXPAYERS WHO NO LONGER WORK AND
EARN TO FUEL THE ECONOMY SO
THOSE TAX DOLLARS, BY THE WAY,
COLLECTED AND RECORD AMOUNT NOW
CAN BE APPLIED TO THE THINGS
THAT THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO?
TAX POLICY MATTERS HERE.
>> Carley: ONE OF THOSE HANDS
ELSE STUDENT LOAN BAILOUTS AND
THE WHITE HOUSE ROLLING OUT THE
FIRST APPLICATIONS THIS
WEEK.
JUST A COUPLE.
>> IT WILL BE $1 TRILLION IN A
TIME SOON.
DON'T YOU CARRY THAT AROUND,
TODD.
>> Todd: THE ONLY ONE THAT WE
WANT IS LAMAR CHECKS AND FINALLY
GIVING US THE GA